allez prendre le support que sont la
grille avant de monter sur le vélo rail
il faut le mériter première étape
apprendre à le retourner on va doucement
va doucement vaut parler trop vite car
ici il n'y a qu'une seule voie et une
fois arrivés au bout des 6 km de rails
il faut remettre l'engin dans le bon
sens pour revenir au point de départ un
peu compliqué de l'équilibré mais non ça
va passer les consignes de sécurité
vraiment isabelle diego et leurs enfants
s'élance sur deux vélos rails une
première pour cette famille
d'eure-et-loir
les enfants
sauf était encore très trop vite
[Musique]
au cir
inauguré en 2008 le vélorail du pays
chartrain a permis de remettre en
service cette ligne abandonnée une
dizaine d'années plus tôt elle servait
au début du 20e siècle à relier chartres
à paris les constructions c'est vers
1905 et ça a été mis en service qu'en
1930 pour rappel disant puisque avec la
2d la seconde guerre mondiale ils ont
arrêté le trafic voyageurs
donc ils s'en sont servis pour la
marchandise aujourd'hui les voyageurs
sont des touristes venus pour beaucoup
de la région comme cette famille du loir
et cher tu m'as le plus qu'on a vu c'est
deschamps mais après c'était beau quand
même avoir un terrain là bas pour
pouvoir pique nique en plus pour le
retour franchement c'est top l'an
dernier ils ont été 13 mille visiteurs à
pédaler sur des rails dans ce bruit de
roulement d'un autre temps